yeah hello and welcome to this
announcement video for the double
feature live stream on chest 24 we have
two been tablet session the first one
would be the German language one there
Fred splits as we see here we'll start
at 6pm central loop in time so
relatively shortly has a bit of a late
announcement video and after that I can
click here we have the English version
the better classic been to blitz in
English language which will be eight in
the evening center you ping time yeah
you have to strike six hours for us east
coast if you are in the US yeah I think
it will be fun hope you will make it you
can just go to the church 24 bedside and
you will find it easily in the schedule
shows can also go directly onto youtube
if you like but make it's a bit better
to do it here because here you have the
chat the YouTube chant is always
disabled because the chance on the
website if you haven't just 24 counts
you can chat if you have a premium
account you can also claiming ok guys i
hope you will join today